news continues to emerge thanks in part
to kyle shanahan the 49ers head coach
who
said not that long ago in a podcast with
michael irvin when talking about the
chances of rookie quarterback trey lance
winning the starting job in san
francisco right away
that he didn't want to create
something that would allow me to
generate
an annoying headline when he pointed out
that in theory yes trey lance could end
up being the starter so in a more recent
podcast with sean mcvay and peter
schrager flying coach
is the name of the podcast shanahan who
for some reason agreed to
step into the lion's den
said all sorts of things did first
and let me just raise a broad
question here here's what i would ask
kyle if i had a chance to talk to him
one-on-one
and i've spoken to him before he's good
friends with chris i like kyle i've said
before
i'm on the record he's got the potential
to be
a bill belichick he is a genius when it
comes to football
specifically offensive football and but
for
rash of injuries last year possibly
would have been back in the super bowl
could be back this year
could be in the annual conversation and
ultimately could have
as many rings as belichick does
i believe that of him as it relates to
his coaching abilities however
and and i'm i'm hesitant to say this
because it cuts against my business
interests he needs to stop talking
take a page from bill belichick and zip
it
don't bear your soul and i want to know
the back story here and maybe i'll
try to find it out how did they get him
to do this was this just an ego thing he
and mcveigh have this rivalry that
you know i'm not going to act like it's
a robber i'm not going to say no to you
because then if i say
no i'm i you know i i'm yeah i don't
have the guts to come
talk to yeah i got the guts to talk to
you i'll talk to i'll talk to one of my
top rivals
young coach younger than me guy who's
taken his team to the super bowl one
year before i took my team to the super
bowl
guy whose team has upgraded this year
and is one of the favorites in the nfc
while my team is trying to
to get its sea legs again yeah i'll do
it i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna shy away from it
he said plenty of things and maybe
there's a strategy there
that i'm not capable of grasping but
again i look at belichick belichick
would have never done a podcast like
that would have never
been so candid about so many different
topics
including most importantly and i'm not
going to get into the other ones because
the
uh hey thanks mcveigh and schreger for
giving us something to write about and
talk about in the middle of july but
what shanahan had to say about matthew
stafford it became
clear that the 49ers wanted
matthew stafford they tried to get in
the mix
for a stafford trade but they got
involved too late
ship had sailed and and frankly
i don't think any of it would have
mattered i think it was
a a deal that was brokered between
lesney the gm of the rams and brad
holmes the gm of the lions who had been
an executive with the rams the
experience with the rams got him the job
the best way to
to hide the debacle that was the jared
goff contract was to put him
in the matthew stafford trade package
in lieu of trading jared goff to some
other team and giving that team a first
round pick to take jared goff that's
what they otherwise would have had to do
to get rid of jared goff if they were
going to upgrade it quarterback this was
perfect this was the
the best way and maybe the only way the
rams could have pulled it off
getting a new quarterback while also
getting rid of the jared goff contract
without it being so conspicuous
that they got rid of the jared goff
contract by giving up a first round pick
so i don't think anything was going to
disrupt that deal i think that's the
unvarnished truth
but when shanahan says yeah we we called
stafford's agent tom condon and it was
too late
okay so what quarterbacks didn't the
49ers want this off season as an upgrade
over jimmy garoppolo
they wanted matthew stafford there's a
belief they wanted sam darnold they
wanted aaron rodgers
that was the news that lit the fuse on
the entire aaron rodgers explosion of
the past couple of months it wasn't the
report from espn that
rogers isn't happy it was the report
from paul allen of kfan
that the 49ers had tried the night
before the draft
to trade for aaron rodgers and then
many in league circles believe
believe and may be right
that when the 49ers traded from 12 to 3.
ultimately investing three first-round
picks and a third round pick
in one player that shanahan wanted mac
jones
and was eventually talked out of it and
or
led to the point where he made the
decision on his own that he wanted trey
lance instead of mack jones
so how many quarterbacks other than
jimmy garoppolo
did you want kyle for 2021
how many it may be easier to list the
guys he didn't want
than the guys that he did want we've got
stafford we've got darnold we've got
rogers we've got mac jones
ultimately trey lance and here's what's
so strange about it and this is why
i've spent the time to kind of make this
point the way that i'd like to
garoppolo's still the starting
quarterback of the san francisco 49ers
what the hell is wrong with this picture
he wanted stafford he wanted this guy he
wanted that guy
and and as of right now if they had to
play a game today and of course they
don't garoppolo would be the starter
and maybe lance will win the job during
camp but i think back to
comments from 49er ceo jed york
right after the draft he did a podcast
with matt mayoko of nbc sports bay area
the idea that if they keep garoppolo for
the next two years while they develop
trey lance that's 50 million dollars
invested in
the development of lance because that's
50 million that jimmy garoppolo will
make over the next two years so
look i i continue to believe
that the 49ers have allowed themselves
to freak out
in the aftermath of not evaluating
patrick mahomes
not wanting tom brady when brady wanted
to play
for the 49ers let's rewind to 2020.
brady becomes a free agent or he's
eventually going to become a free agent
and
the patriots didn't really mind that
multiple teams were tampering with tom
brady
brady makes it known to the 49ers he
wants to come home
he wants to play for the team he grew up
rooting for
a super bowl ready team because they've
just been to the super bowl and but for
jimmy garoppolo not being able to hit an
open emanuel sanders he wasn't quite
wide as open as bruce arians would say
but he was open
championship throw second straight year
a championship throw
isn't made first by goff now by
garoppolo
brady would have made that throw they
didn't want brady
they decided to stick with jimmy
garoppolo
i just think
watching mahomes versus brady in the
super bowl was
in my view the icing on the cake the
cherry on top of the icing on the cake
the dollop of whipped cream on top of
the cherry on top of the icing on top of
the cake
that they had to get rid of jimmy
garoppolo they had to move on from jimmy
garoppolo
and here we are after all of those
machinations after all of those
guys that kyle shanahan was interested
in getting
garoppolo is still the starting
quarterback of the san francisco 49ers
and could be
for all of the 2021
season and possibly beyond
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports